cinéma avec la sortie mercredi prochain
du dernier film de claude berri
l'histoire de deux couples en crise
l'un reste l'autre part l'épilogué déjà
révélé par ce titre avant d'écouter
nathalie baye qui incarne la femme
trompée par excellence dominique poncet
virginie herz nous parle de ce film je
peux te parler à l'institut même je te
demande de renvoyer varient d'un parce
que tu couches avec elle deux hommes
mariés arrivés au mitan de leur vie qui
vont chaque a rencontré une autre femme
que la leur l'un restera finalement avec
son épouse l'autre au contraire changera
de vie ces deux destins d'hommes qui
face à la même situation vont réagir de
façon diamétralement opposées claude
berri a choisi de les compter dans un
seul film intitulé l'un reste l'autre
part j'en étais ou avec qui j'ai en
partie autobiographique mais mais il ya
deux histoires dans le film donc y en a
une qui m'a été inspirée de ma propre
vie je dis bien inspiré pour en faire un
film personnel et même j'espère une
fiction et l'autre qui est et qui est
une histoire qu'on m'a raconté et qui a
rien à voir avec moi c'est ces deux
hommes ont le même problème partir ou
rester voilà à peine si toi tu te
présentes jeudi qui peut faire un livre
sur prouver j'ai dit je vais vous
présenter il s'appelle ma femme c'est
rick monfils
celui qui va partir malgré son
déchirement comme claude berri dans la
vie c'est daniel auteuil qu'il
interprète pierre arditi lui joue celui
qui va rester pour les deux personnages
celui qui joue daniel auteuil est le
mien sont l'endroit et l'envers d'un
même personnage
simplement ils sont dans des feature
différentes l'un et dans le dans le
drame
l'autre est dans une sorte de vaudeville
mais pathétique pour la dernière fois
justement de la renvoyer entre rire et
émotion donc ce film qui mine de rien
montre beaucoup de la fragilité des
hommes et de la force des femmes
je sais que c'est du chantage